comment
écoutez je vais je vais très bien même
si peu à la bourre je me cache pas mais
alors revanche gêneront gênant je me
suis penché sur les séries cette fois ci
plus spécialement sur les séries
africaines
voilà mais juste avant de commencer je
voulais vous passez un petit extrait
d'une télé novelas je me sentais obligé
c'est un petit problème de doublage
voilà pour la séquence que c'est mal
mais alors là vous allez voir vous allez
juger vous allez voir des enfants qui
discutent entre eux parmi eux il ya une
personne qui doit avoir environ 47 ans
et demi problème ils n'avaient pas
d'actrice de son âge pour la double et
du coup ils ont fait doubler par la voix
d'un enfant de 12 ans mais ça se
remarque pas du tout ce qu'elle voudra
je le ferai quand dit tu vas mal aimante
et souviens toi que c'est une surprise
c'est vrai sur ne va pas loin dire un
seul mot oui c'est vrai ça briserait
toute la surprise bien sûr bien sûr oui
c'est vrai qu'on sent pas bon moi
j'aimerais c'est à connaître le nom des
acteurs d'antenne qui qui qui prennent
cesser ces choses là qui les diffusent
voiture là car on aurait dit qu'il fait
toutes les voies compliquées
après ça je me suis focalisé sur les
séries africaines donc c'est les séries
qui sont construites un peu comme toutes
les autres en dedans il ya des
personnages le gentil le méchant le
traître et je crois que le suivant c'est
le gentleman
problème sa prestation de gentleman
n'est pas encore au point au point
d'orgue avec moi amène moi lequel un
joli conte fota à l'hôtel oui oh on va
payer bah ouais c'est le principe en
fait
[Applaudissements]
on fait 50 55 ans sera très bien oui on
en sait alors le petit dans ces séries
c'est que souvent les acteurs sont sans
filtre 1 par exemple il ya un acteur qui
arrivait en retard au conseil du village
heureusement son pote et là bas pour
voilà trouver une petite justification à
son retard malheureusement personne ne
lui a dit qu'il n'était pas obligé
d'être aussi précis justifier un retard
pourquoi le notable tandja coupable
allez venez du petit peu bayer est et
elche c'est là qu'ils allaient alors se
trouver le gars qui a le moins de
répartie de toute l'histoire de la télé
donc je te lenche oui tu des rares
hockey et dans une scène de baston
dessus du lac la clape les mâles briquet
de l'histoire de la série test et toi là
tu vas me fait un
[Applaudissements]
parce que j'aimerais bien je viens
maraîchers mois s'est divisée sur quels
sont alors c'était diffusé sur idf1 ma
pensée sur youtube y en a plein la reine
blanche à les regarder à 150 épisodes
wii alors dans la scène qui suit un
acteur on a surpris deux autres en train
de s'embrasser problème je crois qu'il
n'était pas prêt à les voir s'embrasser
du coup il ya un petit peu stupéfaits
malheureusement ils jouent à peu près
aussi bien la stupeur que moi je joue de
la cornemuse
c'est à dire très mal
allez
le commerce il ouvre des prochaines
heures n'est cependant de notre âme et
la phase initiale
[Applaudissements]